- I wanna be really clear
because there are
a lot of people
who sort of get by on
social media drama.
And there's a throttling
and there's a counterclaim.
Look, we've had false
copyright claims,
we've never lost on those.
Like my half Asian
lawyer, Bill Richmond.
We filed counterclaims.
We've had to file petitions
of information in the past.
This is very different.
This is the big one.
We filed an official notice
that we are filing a
lawsuit with YouTube
and an immediate motion
for an injunctive relief
because we have two strikes
in our account right now.
And we have good
reason to believe
that there may be a third
one that they're looking for.
(gentle upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today
is a man on YouTube.
I think, kind of,
maybe, Steven Crowder.
Welcome back.
- Yeah, no, it depends on
when this is exactly running.
A two-week suspension
from YouTube
from the second hard strike.
So not on YouTube right
now, but once upon a time
the biggest right-leaning
channel ever
in the history of the platform.
- Okay, so let's be clear
about what's going on here.
This is an emergency meeting
of the Rubin-Crowder thing
because you could be booted.
You now have two
strikes on your channel.
I'll let you go into
why you got the strikes.
But in essence, if you
get one more strike,
if you even sniff
near Susan Wojenski,
that's it, your entire
channel, your catalog,
the entire thing,
your business, gone.
- Yeah, yeah.
The business, the 12 to 15
people that I employ, gone.
And by the way, that
means within only a series
of a few months,
you and all other
right-leaning people as well.
Because let's be clear here,
I talked about Michael
in all of this.
I'm basic bitch pumpkin
spice conservatism.
I mean, it's not like
anything that I really believe
is all that radical.
And I've been here since-
- I do always
think of you as basic bitch.
- I really am and it's okay.
It's a moniker that
I wear proudly.
Nothing about me
is very radical.
I'm pro second amendment.
I'm pro first amendment.
I'm pro ending the drug war.
I believe in things like
heartbeat bills with abortion.
It's pretty much conservative,
Christian who advocated
that people do not have
sex until they're married.
I know, crazy.
Keep me away from the kids.
But I wanna be really clear
because there are
a lot of people
who sort of get by on
social media drama.
And there's a throttling
and there's a counterclaim.
Look, we've had false
copyright claims.
We've never lost on those.
Like my half-Asian
lawyer, Bill Richmond.
We filed counterclaims.
We've had to file petitions
of information in the past.
This is very different.
This is the big one.
We filed an official notice
that we are filing a
lawsuit with YouTube
and an immediate motion
for an injunctive relief
because we have two strikes
in our account right now.
And we have good
reason to believe
that there may be a third
one that they're looking for.
How do I know this because-
- They're just weak,
they're just weak.
- Well, weak, right.
And because it's not very clear,
I should say it is very clear
that we didn't violate
specific policies.
And so they said, well, maybe
the totality of InTandem.
So if people wanna
know, and by the way,
people can still watch us.
We're available at
Mug Club, in Blaze
a lot of crowder.com/mug club.
And we always recommend
that people join anyways
because there's an hour worth
of extra content every day
but we're still making sure
that the free
content is available
on Apple and Android, Spotify.
And right now on Rumble
that we can't stream live.
It's a little glitchy
we're working with them.
But the issue here with YouTube,
to give you an idea
on a couple of strikes
the first one that
came in was a warning
that was supposed to be a
hard strike on voter fraud.
Now, I have never said
that Donald Trump
won the election,
that the ghost of Hugo
Chavez rigged Smartmatic
and whisked away, Wisconsin.
But just like Amy Klobuchar
just like Elizabeth Warren,
just like Jimmy Carter.
I say that individual
voter fraud does occur.
And of course, as they said,
it occurs far more with
mass mail-in voting.
Just because there are
fewer checks and balances.
There are fewer ways
to sort of verify.
And so the segment that
we did was almost comical
and us saying,
not that there's anything
wrong with that thing.
Not that there's any vote fraud,
but we cross-referenced
voter rolls
with addresses that didn't
exist on Google earth,
sent interns with a
copy of that day's paper
and an empty lot on
camera live to say, look,
we know that it occurs,
I think it might have
been 30 or 40 addresses.
They said that's a violation
of the election fraud policy.
Okay, the second one was-
- Wait, wait, can
I pause you there?
'Cause I think you're
sort of philosophically
and I don't wanna get
myself booted now too.
But we're not even addressing
the philosophic issue,
which is, should you
be allowed to just say
what you wanna say
in a free country,
on a supposedly open
platform and everything else?
I mean, it's just
worth mentioning that,
that you're saying you
didn't break the rules,
but the question really is,
are the rules just
completely insane?
- No, absolutely.
And by the way,
we were never told that
we were wrong to be clear.
No one has proof.
And matter of fact,
we got fact checked
and some people said
that we were wrong
when really the fact
check ended up being,
they changed the voter
rolls the next night
to a new address
it didn't exist.
That was one that
was part of a series.
So I don't wanna get too
off into the weeds there
but these were things where
we did our due diligence
to a comical degree.
That was the point
of the segment.
The first actual
strike, I believe
I don't remember
the exact sequence,
was COVID, 15 days
to flatten the curve,
or one-year anniversary.
Now, what did we do?
We showed them CDC saying,
don't wear masks, say wear masks
don't wear double
mask, wear double mask.
We won't have a
vaccine in a year.
I wouldn't take the vaccine
if it was done in a
year, take the vaccine.
All of this stuff.
Which is really tough to
navigate as an American.
From what I understand,
the statement that
was a violation
was something to the effect of,
'cause I don't want
you to get booted.
Something to the
effect of the COVID
is significantly more
lethal to old people.
We know that.
We need to figure out how to
protect the most vulnerable.
But for some reason,
due to the immune response,
according to the CDC
and we always list our
references available
on our website.
Young people are significantly
less at risk of death
from COVID than the flu.
For some reason,
young but old people,
it's way more deadly.
We use the CDC mortality tables.
We've even given
a specific reason
as to what the violation is,
but the time code that
I believe we were given
was where that statement
was made and people can,
we're the only show I know of.
If you go to
louderwithcrowder.com,
every single episode has a
page with the references.
The references
for that statement
were the CDC and World
Health Organization.
Now, some people can say, well
you're making it seem like
it's not as big of it.
People may not
take it seriously.
Well, A, that's not
what I'm saying.
And B, if we're gonna
follow the science,
it's important to understand
how different immune systems
respond to a novel virus.
It's important that you
don't tell people, shut up,
if they have a problem with a
two year old wearing a mask.
If you say, well,
hold on a second,
we don't have two or four year
olds wear a mask for the flu,
where there are
significantly more deaths
for younger people.
It is significantly
deadlier for older people
or the immunocompromised.
You're not allowed
to discuss that.
The most recent one.
This is the second strike here.
And this is why
there's a lawsuit,
which I really didn't want
this to have to come to.
I just wanna do the show
as when I was
recently celebrating,
actually praising the officer
who saved that young girl's life
who was about to be
stabbed by Ma'Khia Bryant.
I said, not only
is that a justified
shooting from the police,
I believe it's necessary
because if the police
can not shoot someone
who was in the process of
attempting to stab you,
then we might as
well not have police,
and I believe that we
should have police.
That was considered
bullying harassment.
But not technically,
but the totality,
maybe over time,
indicative of bullying,
harassing by supporting
the police, exactly.
- Who were you bullying
by saying that you supported
the cop saving a woman's life
who was about to be decapitated?
Who was that bullying?
- Apparently, it
might be considered
reveling in the death
of Ma'Khia Bryant.
I don't know.
We don't have an official answer
and we can't get
these official answers
from people at YouTube.
But let me just be really
clear with people out there.
This is tantamount to
saying to everyone out there
if you're conservative,
we don't want you.
Look, if they are saying,
Hey, look, you cannot discuss
the mortality rates of COVID.
You can not point
out that the CDC
has been inconsistent
and confusing
which has made it harder
for Americans to stay safe.
You are not allowed to say
that voter fraud has ever
occurred to any degree.
And you are not allowed
to support police
if they save someone's
life mid stabbing,
if the person
committing the stabbing
happens to be a girl of color.
That is saying,
you are not welcome
on this platform
if you hold these views.
Now, if they say
that, that's fine.
The issue there is, I'm
pro-business, I'm anti-fraud.
YouTube says all
views are welcome.
Those strikes
without description,
tell us otherwise.
We need to know the rule book
because people's
livelihoods depend on it.
- Well, Crowder,
last week I put up an
interview with David Horowitz.
I'm sure you know,
David Horowitz.
- Of course.
- And I've never in all of
my years of doing this show,
I've never edited for content,
except one time I
had a guest come on,
who was drunk and stoned.
And we ended up editing
just to basically save
this person's career.
It's the only time
we've edited for time.
- I did that once too.
We can compare
notes off the air.
This person was doing
crack in the laundry room.
No joke, yeah.
- It was probably
the same person.
But last week,
for the first time
we edited for content
because David Horowitz
is a free man.
And what I thought
was a free country
dared to say two sentences
that I knew my channel
could be deleted like that.
So we had to, we
censored it on YouTube.
I mean, simple as that.
I put it up in my
locals community
but now I'm having you, you
crazy right wing maniac guy-
- Well, you're such a tease
and now I wanna hear
the two sentences.
And that's the issue.
What's gonna happen is
all people wanna
hear the sentences
and they assume that if it's
like not seeing the monster
in a scary movie,
you assume that it's
worse than it is.
That's how you
radicalize people.
When you see these New
York Times articles saying,
Hey, radicalization,
and it has a picture with
me next to Philip DeFranco.
And then by the way-
- Hey, hey, give
me a little credit
I was in there, c'mon.
- Were you in there too?
- Yeah, I was in there.
- Okay, that's right.
Yeah, I just,
again, I would never imagine
that you would be in there
radicalizing people, Dave Rubin.
- Credit-wise too, man.
- But what happens
is then they complain
about echo chambers.
Well, look, what's more radical
a view of someone
who believes what,
the guy who believes
in a flat tax
or the people who believe
in 90% income tax.
The guy who believes that
police need to be demilitarized
to a degree,
but that they also need
to be able to do their job
and they should wear body cams.
Or the people who believe
we should have no
police whatsoever.
We should have no
prisons whatsoever.
Like Rashida Tlaib, like AOC.
Like these people believe.
this is not a radical
point of view.
The reason for this
lawsuit is, look,
could I, at some point
sail off into the sunset
with support from
people at Mug Club?
I don't know, but at
some point I could.
But what about the next kid
who wants to start a business?
I started this in
2009, maybe 2008,
with the blue bed
sheet behind me.
I don't see a world in
which their point of view
is even allowed to be expressed.
Now, we talk about
othering people.
YouTube is othering an
entire half of the country.
And by the way, more
than 80% of black people
while we're talking
about the Ma'Khia Bryant
and that officer's situation,
more than 80% of black people
want at least as much of a
police presence as exists now,
if not more.
And because that isn't a
view that is permissible,
we silence these minorities too.
We host people in our...
Look, if the guy who
did change my mind
which was antithetical
to the sort of 24
hour news cycle,
"if it bleeds, it leads."
If that's removed
as impermissible,
no conservative viewpoint
is permissible on YouTube.
- Well, I think you know Crowder
I don't think I'm
enlightening you
when I tell you that you know
what this really
of course is about,
is that you are changing minds.
You have an absolutely
extraordinarily huge channel.
How many people did you
have on election night
before they took you down?
How many people were watching?
- Gosh, I don't know.
It was at any given point,
something like
600,000 cumulatively.
It was like 16 million
You know, and look, I hate
doing this 'cause you know-
- No, it's important
- That we've had people.
- I get it.
It's not just blowing you up.
But the point is,
you have influence.
- Yeah, and we're talking
about billions of plays.
- Why are they always
trying to take out Tucker?
I mean, we know why,
it's not about Tucker,
it's about the people
- Yeah, it's about
billions of plays.
Billions of plays
across our platform.
And if you include my...
It's one of those things
that I say it on knees,
I'm so grateful for it.
And I know that all
this could go away
and I could annoy people
and they don't wanna watch
the show, that's fine.
But it needs to occur
in an honest platform.
And important thing too,
a lot of people think
this doesn't affect them.
They go, "Oh, he's a dick."
Like, guilty.
However, if you're
a business owner,
you wanna conduct business
now in the 21st century.
This is a town square,
230, not even withstanding.
But you know this,
YouTube, Twitter, Facebook
they go to business owners.
They come to us and
say, advertise with us.
You get to keep the subscribers
you gain if you advertise.
You get to keep the
followers that you gain.
If you wanna open up a shop,
and you don't advertise
online, you haven't got a shot.
And this is an issue of
dishonest business practices.
If they are choosing
not only politically
winners and losers, as
it relates to business,
they can do this with anyone.
I'm pro-business,
I'm anti fraud.
And with YouTube right
now, here's the issue.
You have what, you have
community guidelines.
Okay, that's one set of rules.
That's set by YouTube.
YouTube says advertiser
friendly guidelines
are set by sponsors.
Well, I've tried to be a
sponsor and I've advertised.
I've never once been requested,
"Hey, where would you like
to advertise your content?"
Matter of fact, they've
precluded me from doing it.
And I've been a content creator
where I can't accept
certain sponsors.
And then we have
a third category
which no one really
knows, isn't defined
which is borderline.
And we don't know
who determines that.
They're all determined by
YouTube at the end of the day.
Yes, I asked borderline Dave
Rubin, the radicalization,
the third Reich, Mr. Rubin.
- The funny thing about that
article in the New York Times
about the radicalization
to the far right,
is yeah, you and DeFranco
and Jordan Peterson
and Milton Friedman,
who's a real nut bag.
You guys were all on the
cover of the print one.
You had to open to page
three to get my picture
except it was a huge
picture of my face
under something like,
"Leading them to the alt-right.
My dad had no idea,
my dad had no idea.
But boy, putting aside the
specifics of the politics,
and I get it.
People know that you don't
want the government involved
and they get the difference
between platform and
publisher and all that stuff.
Just on the pure, like you're
suing YouTube side of this.
It can't be that much fun.
I think I sorta asked
you to go that last time.
Like the idea that you're
going up against Goliath
like it's not like
a great pleasure.
- No, it's not something
that I wanna do at all.
And I wish it could be settled
and I wish that we
could have had answers.
And look, I just
wanna do my show
unlike with Joe Rogan,
for example, on Spotify.
something like 40 something
episodes were removed
and it was done in
the dead of night.
Look, this is why
we have Mug Club-
- You let them do it
though, just for the record.
I mean, (indistinct)
- Right, now to be clear
what happened with
the Vox Adpocalypse,
there were conversations
behind the scenes
which hopefully I
have to be careful
as to what I discuss,
what I don't.
But we were very public.
We said, look,
we have to remove 30
something videos from YouTube
because they may be borderline,
even though they're
not violating policy.
These aren't
available at Mug Club.
Didn't wanna do it,
it wasn't a violation
of policies,
but I was saying,
Hey, this is an
act of good faith.
It's YouTube sandbox.
They can determine the rules.
And we were transparent
about saying that
off platform at Mug Club.
And these might've
been radical views.
Like life begins at conception
or something like that.
Something that should never
be permissible on YouTube.
We were very
straightforward with it.
Our entire catalog has been
audited at great length.
And now these are new
potential violations
that may or may not exist.
Look, we've had to reinvent.
This is why I say, I'm
about to be a father of two.
I employ, I think it's
14 people right now.
And then, this is
the first people
that I think of when I get up
and the last people I think of
when I go to sleep.
Because they don't have
the control that I do
in fighting YouTube and
making these decisions.
My decisions affect them.
We've had to fundamentally
change our business model
and we figured out, oh, wait
if you search Steven Crowder,
change my mind abortion,
you find an old PBS
video with 400 views.
We can no longer rely
on search or browse.
Okay, we're gonna focus on
not just subscriptions
but notifications.
Wait, notifications
no longer really work.
So we moved to a live show.
We can't edit because we go
live and we just tell people
and it still isn't Mug Club,
weekdays at 10:00 AM Eastern
to the point where,
it doesn't matter if we
don't show up in search,
don't show up in browse,
it doesn't matter
if subscriptions or
notifications work.
We have a baseline of
millions of viewers
who will tune in every day.
And we're always at the top
of the YouTube live page.
They can't control it
because it's more popular
than other programs.
I think this is sort of the
last decision they can make
considering that we've
consistently adapted to rules
that are not applied
to anyone else.
I am such a passivist.
I so I'm a conflict avoider.
But my belief is,
you avoid, avoid,
avoid, avoid, avoid.
And then if you have to
engage in a conflict,
you make it as swift and
effective as you possibly can.
And I wish that we
hadn't crossed that line.
I wished that YouTube hadn't.
I hope they do the right thing
and I don't wanna
do this but we will.
- Have you ever met
Susan, the CEO of YouTube?
Have you ever met her?
- Never, which is bizarre
when you see her
mentioning me by name
at the Recode conference,
with someone who works
for Vox interviewing her,
it's surreal, it really is.
- Was that the interview
where they said,
Dave Rubin is the gateway drug
to guys like Steven Crowder.
I think that might've been it.
Is that the one?
I'm not kidding,
I'm not kidding.
There was one talk.
I don't know if it was that one.
- You were the Molly to my MDMA.
I don't know, maybe.
It could be, but it's
bizarre for me...
- Is that the one you
do Molly first or well-
- I honestly, I don't.
Basic bitch like I
said, I don't know.
- Let me ask you one more thing.
'Cause we're just
doing this quick.
'Cause I just wanted to
get word out about this
'cause it's important.
- Thank you, I appreciate it.
- Because, the truth is,
I mean, we're friends
but the truth is, if you
go down then you're right.
It's the flood
gates on everybody.
But so let me just ask
you this to finish.
Do you sort of feel like
this with you and YouTube
is just directly connected
to everything going on
in society right now
which is that all the things
that guys like us have
been screaming about
and warning against,
it's all here, it's
at the doorstep.
That's sort of what
you were saying.
Like it's just like,
it's all just arrived.
And whether it's Crowder
being taken off YouTube,
or attacking people
in the streets
or changing every norm in
our political discourse,
it's all here.
- Look, people need
to understand the
world that we live.
Laws are being suspended.
What do I mean?
Right now you have
people complaining
like there are laws in Florida
that it will just
make it easy for you
to run over protestors.
I go, "Hold on a second,
hold on a second."
We're talking about a riots
and we're talking about people
being dragged out of their cars.
Hold on, is it
illegal to congregate
in the middle of a freeway?
- I think it is.
- It is, it's illegal.
But we've just decided we
don't enforce those laws.
So we've decided
to suspend the law
and instead turn
Americans into criminals,
Americans with vehicles,
Americans who legally
purchased firearms.
We've decided to turn
them into criminals.
Now, maybe Americans who
speak out against policies,
turn them into criminals.
I will say this,
look, with YouTube,
to go back to the idea
of publisher platform.
I don't think it's
ever been more clear
than to use Twitter
as an example.
I mean, President, Donald Trump
wasn't really on YouTube.
They remove a sitting president
for saying fight like hell.
And look, I don't care.
I don't even think
it's controversial.
Anyone who acts as
a fight like hell
has not been a phrase
that has been used as
a colloquialism for,
is being intellectually
dishonest.
So that's why we sell the fight
like hell shirt at Crowder shop.
- I'm pretty sure Maxine
Waters has said worse.
- Yes, she has said worse
and she has done worse.
Look at the size
of those pupils.
So he was removed though.
Twitter said that's
a bridge too far.
- Okay, the Ayatollah
Khamene is still on Twitter.
Hamas is still on Twitter,
who a part their
charger is not...
By the way, don't say
eradication of Israel,
all Jews.
And we're also,
we're talking about
anti-Semitic hate crimes
that could potentially be
inspired by Donald Trump
here at home.
Look, that is an
editorial decision.
In other words, if Twitter
says this is too far
for Donald Trump to be on
Twitter or YouTube or Facebook,
that means that they
are consciously saying,
Hamas is not too far.
The Ayatollah not too far.
And that cannot come with
the same legal protections
of a platform like
AT&T or Verizon.
That has an editorial decision
just like the New York Times,
just like the Washington post.
And just like YouTube saying,
you can't praise an officer
for saving a girl's life
from being stabbed.
We can't allow it.
We can't allow that to go on.
- Isn't it a weird position
that for guys like us
like I do think about it
often where I'm like, man,
if YouTube servers blew up,
but I think about it usually
more related to Twitter.
if Twitter just cease
to exist tomorrow
and all the data was destroyed,
all of the followings,
all of that stuff,
like it feels to me,
and I actually don't mean
this on the YouTube side.
On the Twitter
side specifically.
Like the world would be better.
That's a very weird thing
for guys like Chris to think.
- Yeah, I know.
But you know, I don't
know about YouTube
because where would people find
their hardcore pornography?
We have found by the
way, just so people know-
- Hardcore porn on YouTube?
- Yes, yes.
And there's also guys who play,
listen, we've done this
on the show dick or dildo.
It's two homosexual gentlemen
who put up a sheet and
play dick or dildo,
where the guy is
facing the camera.
And he has to guess if
it's a dick or a dildo.
By the way, the
answer's always dick.
It's never a dildo.
This is on YouTube, and it's
not even age restricted.
Now, I will say this.
I know, look, and people know
that, I'm not trying
to shock people.
when we cite facts, when
we give out references,
they're all publicly
available on the website.
I don't know any other
show that does that.
You're talking about on average,
anywhere from 40 to 60
per day, we make a joke.
It may offend people.
You may not find it funny.
You may not like it, but
you have to acknowledge
that it's a joke and
the standard can be,
does it offend you,
the standard that
YouTube has to apply.
And I'm gonna use
some language here
because I'm quoting directly,
Stephen Colbert and
Samantha Bee is,
did Steven Crowder say
anything more offensive
than referring to a
sitting president's mouth
as "Putin's cock holster?"
Did he bully anyone
worse than Samantha Bee
with a national
platform on television
referring to the first
lady as a "feckless cunt."
Nope, that's the standard
that has to be applied equally
not if it offends somebody.
And because that's not
the kind of language
or spirit of the comedy
that I would ever use,
facts and information
not withstanding.
- Well, Crowder,
I just wanna say that it's
been nice knowing you.
And Susan, if you're watching,
I didn't wanna do this.
I was forced into it
because Crowder is
very influential
and threatened me.
And this has been a
hostage situation.
And I'm so sorry to
have this discussion
about free speech
and open discourse.
Crowder, final word.
- You should have never given
me access to your iCloud.
So they're gonna expect many
more of these interviews
if I'm the platform.
I'll be lording over
that YouTube forever.
Now look, I appreciate it.
And like I said, this is a...
If I thought it was
just about our channel,
you know, it wouldn't
be that big a deal.
I really do.
I'm afraid that there won't
be these opportunities
for anybody else out there
who have an alternative
point of view.
When we talk about the
young kid who's bullied,
I think of the
young kid right now
who grew up in
this pandemic era,
where their parents are punished
if they even speak out
with an alternative opinion
let alone what they
see on social media
and people's lives destroyed.
And now, as a matter of
potentially official policy
combined with a culture
that is designed
to completely remove the
idea of right and wrong,
but only seeing the general
through the lens of the
oppressed and the oppressor
and turn everyone into
good little rule followers
without questioning
whether the rules
are just or if they're
applied justly.
I'm really scared for that.
And that's why we're doing,
that's why we filed this
official notification
of a lawsuit.
I don't wanna do it, but I
just don't see any other way
unless they get
their button here.
- Crowder, joking aside,
I'm completely with you on this.
I will support you
in any way I can.
- Thank you.
- We are proxies
for a lot of people
in this crazy thing.
And you're huge right now,
and they wanna make
an example of you.
I will fight with you
until the end, man.
- Thank you sir.
- But I will go down,
because what was the
other YouTube channel?
- "Dick or Dildo," yeah.
- Okay, all right,
see you later.
If you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about comedy
instead of the nonstop yelling
you get everywhere else,
check out our comedy playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out our full episode playlist
they're both right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.